hey Simon welcome to my condo this is
the first video that I'm shooting on my
new camera I just got a cannon xa10 out
of the box so hopefully it comes out
loud if I have he's careful what but it
looks pretty awesome so today today I am
excited i just bought a irobot roomba
I've been looking for a way to easily
clean up my condo get dust and hair crap
everywhere so this thing is let's make
our lives super easy so I just came back
from the store and I want to open it up
you guys and see how it works
instruction manual I almost never read
these and we'll see how it goes
it comes with this big stop sign here
it's great stop if you have any
questions about your i Brobot product
we'd like to return it please contact us
first a friend of support stock is here
to help component so we'll see if we
need to use out of them okay so the idea
behind the iRobot is you have a base
station that you plug into the wall I
haven't figured out how to plug this in
it okay okay to plug it up like this so
we have a base station this plugs into
the wall and then the vacuum here sits
somehow in here and then we'll go around
the entire condo picking up hair and
dust and everything and then when it's
done it'll come back to extinction in
charge that's the theory so let's see
what I
this actually looks pretty simple I've
only got three pieces I've got the robot
vacuum the charger and I guess that's
only two pieces so I'm just going to
look look at the instructions quickly to
see if I missing anything important I
don't know what this thing does I'm
gonna connect somehow so quick reading
instruction man let's see if is anything
simple I like simple setup ring
instruction manual I almost never read
these so we'll see how it goes sometimes
they have the little pictures usually
doing five steps so we'll see it as
anything like that quick start guide see
this is what I need I do not want to
read the whole book owners manual the
quick start guide that's what I'm all
about so I'm a little sad because before
I can use it I need to charge it
overnight such a downer I just got this
thing and I want to use it and now I
have to charge it overnight guys it
should come pre charge that least from
your first views so i don't have to plug
it in and then finish this video
tomorrow after I've let it go over there
now the one thing I wanted to try to do
was I don't like a lot of clutter so I
wanted to put this someone forgot where
can I put it that's not going to look
ugly and go clean we're so
everything what can I so yeah yeah I had
was to put it under my couch so I
haven't plugged behind here I'm gonna
plug it in behind there and let it
charge and then hopefully it'll work
farts way around the ship it okay well
I'm gonna test it out I'm going to
charge it up and we'll see how it goes I
discovered something really important by
reading my Quick Start Guide let me zoom
in here it says so it says charge it
overnight or until the clean button
light turns green and I'm excited to say
that the button turn green so I'm going
to go back over to my Roomba and you can
see that the button is solid green so we
are ready for action and let's see what
happens now my original plan what I
wanted to do was have it go under my
couch and I wanted the film it so that I
wouldn't know where is it going to come
out the big surprise but unfortunately
it doesn't fit what happens here let me
let me show you guys there's this little
point here this is I'm assuming what
connects the devices so this is a
charging station this is the actual
vacuum and these parts connect this it
just just tall enough that it doesn't
fit under the stainless steel part of my
couch so I have to kind of hide it in
the corner here instead of allowing to
go under the couch which means it's not
going to clean under my couch which is a
little annoying but anyway let's see how
it goes so I'm going to press the clean
button which I'm assuming is what I have
to do and let's see what happens you are
get a nice song
and there goes
so it's really kind of getting stuck
around my dining room chairs but it
seems I've kind of found the way out
let's see what happens okay well I'm
going to pause it here and hopefully
this thing will at some point return
back to it's charging station and have a
whole ton of dirt with it the Roomba has
found its way I would have a mess of
chairs and is now going through the
bedrooms the kitchen making its way
around definitely have with a home base
next to a bunch of chairs it's hard
because it keeps bouncing around but
with big open spaces like that it's
covering a ton of space any little thing
of dirt or feathers or whatever on the
floor it's picking up so far doing a
pretty good job I don't know how long
this will go for it's been going for
almost 20 minutes now we'll see i'll
keep you guys posted but so far so good
it's a little noisy definitely want to
run it when i am not in the house but
this is pretty cool we'll see how it
goes so it's one in the morning this
thing has been going for about two and a
half hours we just actually had a major
power failure and the electricity just
came back on the room but just made a
noise is saying that it ran out of
battery and i have to put it back so i
don't know if it would have found its
way back to its home if we didn't have
the power failure if you look outside
here there's buildings way down there
they don't have any power the street
lights just came on but those buildings
down in the distance this building right
here kind of hard to see I guess I back
it out you might be able to see better
there's no power out there so still a
major power outage from a big ice storm
here in Toronto so I'm going to pick
this guy up put him back to his charging
station I'm getting tired it's past one
in the morning and so he's been going
for I guess two and a half hours
yeah two and a half hours so that lasted
a while we'll put them back in the
charging station and tomorrow I guess
see how much dirt it was able to pick up
put it back in the orange light is
charging that's it for tonight we'll see
what happened tomorrow
we have had a crazy ice storm and are
completely out of power it's noon here
and you can see the houses are all full
of ice and snow and we've had no power
so we're afraid to open the fridge you
see what's in there back to our friend
the Roomba this was actually kind of fun
last night so I was it was going around
we were following it from room to room
and seeing what was going and seeing
what would pick up as you saw it ran out
of battery because we also had a power
outage so it hasn't charged because we
still don't have any power but I want to
see what it picked up so see we can open
this up and see where the dirt is pull
that out and wow that is some serious
gross dirt that I need to take to the
garbage okay here we go let's see how
much crap I can't get extra light
because we have no power but let's this
up ah look at this gross pneus and we
had actually pretty clean clothes oh man
it just keep wow that is nasty it just
keeps coming okay so a lot of crap that
came out of our condo and it's usually
pretty clean so the room but did a
decent job the next thing I want to
figure out is there's an option here to
schedule if you look at the front here
it says scheduled on clock and so this
thing was kind of noisy and bounced
around so what I wanted to do was have
it to operate when I wasn't home and
come back to clean place and so when I
get power back I'm going to see if I can
figure out a way to schedule this thing
at the top but also says day hour minute
so i'll see how we can hopefully get
something to going maybe a daily at noon
clean up the whole place and hopefully
it'll find its way back to its base
station i will keep you posted
and we still have no power it's been
over 24 hours of no power hot water heat
we're freezing here so I don't have an
update on the roomba because it's no
electricity we're living by candlelight
here you can see the whole place is dark
and luckily my video camera still works
at a nice good charge if you look at it
it's just pure darkness apart from this
the the lights on the highway that this
should be all lit up so there's a few
lights some people still have power down
there in the distance but anyway let's
see you can't even make out where the
roomba is here it's just black so
hopefully we'll see when this all comes
back up and I'll give you an update on
how to get the settings going so it
comes and cleans your house daily and
see if that works I'm out have a good
night and we'll talk to you soon so it's
now monday the 23rd i still have no
power my room but still sitting there on
the floor it is cold in here usually the
Sun comes in these huge windows and
warms up the condo I don't actually have
to use much heat but it's a really car
today still and it is cold I don't know
how cold it is but it is it is freezing
in here so you can see all the houses
are still covered with ice we've had
three hundred thousand households here
that have no power another one how many
people are in a household but you're
looking at half a million people
probably who are still out of power and
it is cold so I took a few things out of
my fridge and just put them outside
looks like the coke blew away they're
just a meet and orange hues and stuff
just a little wouldn't go bad in the
fridge it in the freezer but everything
else is pretty bad and I have no food
and I am cold so I'm gonna have to find
a place to work and to eat and we'll see
what is open around here there's there's
been a massive run on supplies
gas stations are rammed like lineups for
an hour more probably just trying to get
gas so it's kind of crazy here 36 hours
no power we'll see what happens during
the day we'll see if I can get online
somewhere last night I had to go to
Nina's parents place which is maybe half
an hour north just to charge our laptops
and phones so for the canyons doing well
though here this camera is still at 77
minutes of battery life so I can film
for a while longer there in the distance
you can see Toronto there's our CN Tower
I don't know if they have lights but I
see some smoke coming off their building
so hopefully everybody there is okay so
I'm out on the street and thought i'd
give you a different perspective i just
pulled out my camera and you can see
everything is just ice this is solid ice
if you look up at the trees you can see
that everything is just totally frozen
solid here
we get closer and look at the branches
just ice everywhere the whole city is
covered in ice so I'm making my way
north you can see traffic is crazy the
company I invested in trying to dance
salsa is a little bit north of here I'm
gonna see if they have power because if
they do there's an Internet there so I
want to be able to go there hopefully be
able to set up for the day get some food
but are going to
tim hortons which is my favorite place
to get some coffee and some food
hopefully I can go in and whoa Tim
Hortons is lined up packed with people
so i am not going to go there all right
the hunt for new food begins I'll check
in shortly I'm at the corner of yonge
and sheppard here it's a pretty busy
intersection for us I like yuengling
Sheppard this is where I work is where I
live the lights are out let's see if I
could zoom in here on that light the
lights are totally out there are no this
is usually the Walker stop sign for
pedestrians so people are just kind of
doing their own thing I don't know how
pedestrians are going to go across
there's no lights nobody seems to be
hitting each other so I'm just going to
go and see what happens
not hit for anybody yet people have
respect for the road Canadians right
nice people
alright i'm heading still north to
toronto dance salsa in my search my
quest for food for power and for
internet oh here's McDonald's
McDonald's is closed open christmas day
but it's closed today too bad it's the
23rd so we have a few days until
Christmas and they're seeing the power
should be on hopefully Christmas morning
but maybe after so we've still got a
number of days left before we get power
here but hopefully they can figure it
out quickly and get us some power all
right I'll check in soon I'm still
making my way north to Tirana dance
salsa and came across this restaurant
Sheila Rollins it's small family-owned
business and you can see that the tree
here basically just fell right on top of
the house hopefully there's not too much
damage there there's so much debris
everywhere this branches falling down
everywhere ice everywhere you can see
here on the street
they just put the branches all of these
branches were all over the road all over
the sidewalk people couldn't get by the
first thing that the crews were doing
we're just trying to get the stuff off
the street so that you know we could we
could move but I don't know I just feel
so bad you got these entrepreneurs it's
hard enough running the business hard
enough running a restaurant and to have
this this thing happen is sucks it sucks
but we will survive we will keep going
and I am making my way north to trauma
dance salsa and hopefully I have power
now unfortunately to to bicyclists left
their bikes here and it just got
pummeled I don't know these guys are
going to get their bikes out until the
spring thaw comes but just another sign
of what's happening here in Toronto so I
made it here to Toronto guide salsa I'm
standing outside the building and
unfortunately it is closed no power
nothing going on inside there's a
security at the front here who are
holding the gate shut I'm not letting
people in because there's no power
except for the guards to working with
hydro the hydrant company so
the March continues I don't know what
I'm going to do next but I'm searching
for some internet and some power and
some food and hopefully doesn't take too
long for everything to get settled up so
it's a 10 in the morning it is minus 4
degrees I just found out that TDS is
struggling this house is gonna be close
and so I had the message Jason to let
him know because Jason is one of the
guys on my team he showed up at the
office and I said I was going to go to
turn I saw somebody to come along but I
gotta let him know that it's closed and
i'm still searching so we'll keep you
posted TD s closed closed
the hunt
continues
stay warm
alright hopefully he's ok he's at the
office with no power no heat too
hopefully we can find a place somewhere
close to actually get some stuff done so
with frontal dance salsa close i'm going
to take the bus to get back instead of
walking and i found a nice power station
here so i can charge my phone and my
sixty percent right now hopefully can
get a bus get back find the car and go
on the hunt i'm gonna have to drive
north and find maybe a starbucks that I
can work from the hopeful isn't to pack
because as you solve the to morton's
everything here is crazy packed you
can't get any access so stay tuned hope
you'll get some work done today and have
some food in my stomach alright it's
nighttime here it's about 1040 and the
good news is we have power so after
about 40 hours not having any power no
heat no hot water it's finally I'll back
on and it's great to be back in in the
condo and be able to get online and
everything so to finish up with this
video when we started here is the Roomba
it's all powered up the last thing I
want to do is figure out how to set the
time for those of you who are kind of
wondering what what just happened
because the last video i think i was at
the bus stop ended up calling nina inch
and went to her office and used her
internet and hung out there for the day
it's about 45 minutes away from where i
live i couldn't take videos there
because she's not allowed to have video
cameras there so this is why i'm
updating you guys from home so the one
thing that i found was really cool about
this was they had an option here if you
can get closer day hour minute and the
ability to schedule a time so i want to
see how that works would be really cool
for this thing to run on its own when
i'm not around so schedule i'm not sure
how this works
sunday 12 o'clock no one o'clock now
let's try 12 by 1pm s fire Sunday 1pm
clock it thinks it's tuesday at five
thirty seven a.m. so i need to change
that and the schedule just click
schedule and pick the time and hopefully
that will run so it seems pretty easy
enough if I just change around the clock
and then set the schedule for each day
to run at one o'clock and hopefully
we'll keep my place nice and tidy anyway
huh see if I can get myself on camera
here you can kind of see me there it's
been a crazy past two days I'm just glad
that hey I've got a clean apartment
thanks to the Roomba and we've got power
for everybody in Toronto still looks
like a lot of buildings out there have
no power you can see there in the
distance so I'm one of the lucky ones
it's a estimated that a lot of people
still won't have any power for Christmas
which kind of sucks but opportunities
like this bring people together so I'm
going to get ready for bed I am
exhausted thank you guys for watching
this hope you enjoyed this series of
videos if you did please give it a
thumbs up below that always makes you
want to do more and let me know what you
think leave a comment as usual I love
hearing your feedback and your comments
thank you guys and I'll see you soon